This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This past fall, 200 people gathered at the Explorers Club in New York City. The building was once a clubhouse to famed naturalists and explorers. Now it's an archive of ephemera and rarities from pioneering expeditions, from treks to the world's tallest mountains, the North Pole, and the Moon. Woolly mammoth tusks frame a fireplace, a menacing polar bear towers near the landing with claws at the ready. And a cheetah rumored to have been shot by Teddy Roosevelt sits on a plinth just upstairs. The gathering was an honor of a
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。去年秋天，200人聚集在纽约市的探险家俱乐部。这座建筑曾是著名博物学家和探险家的俱乐部会所。如今，它成了开创性探险活动的珍品和稀有物品档案馆，从世界最高峰的跋涉到北极和月球的探索，应有尽有。猛犸象牙装饰着壁炉，一只威风凛凛的北极熊在楼梯平台附近昂首挺立，利爪蓄势待发。楼上的一座底座上，还陈列着一只据传由西奥多·罗斯福射杀的猎豹。这次聚会是为了纪念一场
new expedition. One in search, not of a single animal, but a thousand. Best reporter, Caitlin Swaljay. The club was hosting a biological census. An ecological survey so difficult, so complicated, so taxing, that it had never been attempted before, and may never be attempted again. It is a really big project. Like, I don't think we've ever been involved in a project of this scope in our lives. It's like moving a little, a small little army around.
新的探险。这次探险寻找的不是某种单一的动物，而是上千只。特约记者凯特琳·斯瓦尔杰。该俱乐部正在进行一项生物普查。这项生态调查极其困难、复杂且繁重，此前从未有人尝试过，未来可能也不会再有人尝试。这确实是一个宏大的项目。我觉得我们这辈子从未参与过如此规模的项目。这就像是在指挥一支小小的军队。
This is Jamie Allen. The census was his idea. And when he started, it was a small operation. But now Jamie is merely the tip of a vast pyramid Census was his idea. And when he started, it was a small operation. But now Jamie is merely the tip of a vast pyramid of Census-related personnel, including a logistics chief, a chief cartographer, a veterinarian, an epidemiologist, a specialist from the Fish and Wildlife Service, and of course, a web team. And that's just the core staff.
这是杰米·艾伦。这次普查是他的主意。刚开始时，这只是一个小规模行动。但现在，杰米仅仅是庞大的普查相关人员金字塔的顶端，其中包括后勤主管、首席制图师、兽医、流行病学家、来自鱼类及野生动物管理局的专家，当然，还有一个网络团队。而这还只是核心工作人员。
Below them are the foot soldiers, the volunteers who must go out into the field and do the actual counting. 300 plus volunteers, counting 700 hectares, 100 meter by 100 meter, and 3,000 plus sheets of paper that we have to... It's... yeah. A vast filing system, multiple offices, and a team of hundreds, all for the sake of answering one question. I want to know how many squirrels are in Central Park.
在他们之下是基层人员，即必须深入实地进行实际清点的志愿者。300多名志愿者，清点700公顷土地，每块100米乘100米，还有3000多张纸需要我们……这真是……唉。一个庞大的归档系统，多个办公室，以及数百人的团队，这一切都是为了回答一个问题。我想知道中央公园里有多少只松鼠。
Squirrels, they're counting squirrels. Date, October 14th, 2018. Time, five, twenty-six. On a chilly Sunday evening, I'm following Stu. One of the Central Park Census volunteers around the Parks and Northern end. We're on the hunt for Eastern Grey squirrels, which is like the squirrel. It's what you'll find in just about any American city, but especially Central Park. So we need to be on this path down there. OK. How do we get it?
松鼠，他们在清点松鼠。日期，2018年10月14日。时间，五点二十六分。在一个寒冷的周日傍晚，我跟着斯图。他是中央公园普查的志愿者之一，在公园北端活动。我们正在搜寻东部灰松鼠，这就像是松鼠的代名词。你在几乎任何美国城市都能见到它，但在中央公园尤其多。所以我们需要走那条路。好的。我们怎么过去？
Well, I'm going to, I'll pretend you're not here, right? I just keep doing it. Yeah, yeah. Following his lead, we head off the path over fences and through tall brush. My face is going to be covered in poison. I'm going to stare. We're slowly making our way to his designated area,
嗯，我就假装你不在，好吗？我继续做我的事。好的，好的。跟随他的指引，我们离开小路，翻过栅栏，穿过茂密的灌木丛。我的脸要被毒藤蹭到了。我要盯着看。我们正慢慢前往他负责的区域，
Hector 38E. Hector is our plots of land that measure a little less than two and a half acres each. The job of a census volunteer is to count all the squirrels they can find within their assigned hectares and only their assigned hectares. Although this doesn't stop stew from getting incredibly excited by every squirrel he sees. Oh look, this is cool. I can't count you buddy, you're not in my Hector. Come on back. See you later. After every Hector in the park has been surveyed, all the data will get plugged into a wildlife counting formula popularized by the great mid-century Danish American squirrel biologist Vaughn Fleeger.
38E号公顷。公顷是我们划分的土地单位，每块面积略小于2.5英亩。普查志愿者的工作是清点他们所负责公顷内能找到的所有松鼠，且仅限于他们负责的区域。尽管这并没有阻止斯图对看到的每一只松鼠都感到无比兴奋。哦看，这只真酷。我不能数你，伙计，你不在我的公顷范围内。快回去吧。回头见。在公园里的每一公顷土地都被调查完毕后，所有数据将被输入到一个由20世纪中叶伟大的丹麦裔美国松鼠生物学家沃恩·弗莱格推广的野生动物计数公式中。
The formula will account for squirrels that were double counted and ones no one managed to find. And then finally spit out a number that the world has been waiting for. The formula will account for squirrels that were double counted and ones no one managed to find. And then finally spit out a number that the world has been waiting for. The squirrel abundance number, the total population of Eastern Grey squirrels in Central Park. Give or take. At which point you would be totally justified in asking, as many do, what precisely is the point in knowing the Squirrel abundance number? What they're saying is like, you're counting squirrels.
该公式将剔除重复计算的松鼠，并补上没人发现的松鼠。最后吐出一个全世界都在等待的数字。该公式将剔除重复计算的松鼠，并补上没人发现的松鼠。最后吐出一个全世界都在等待的数字。松鼠丰度数值，即中央公园东部灰松鼠的总种群数量。大概就是这样。此时，你完全有理由像许多人一样问：准确知道松鼠的丰度数值到底有什么意义？他们说的是，你是在数松鼠。
Like, squirrels have a specific context in people's minds. And it's to be ignored. Like, it's assumed, I think, that because they're so common, we know everything we need to know about squirrels, but it's the opposite's true. The very fact that no one has bothered to do a Central Park squirrel census before, together this most basic of data points about one of the most common animals in our landscape, reveals a kind of societal blind spot we have in regard to squirrels. For a long time now, we've taken them for granted, including the story of where all these
松鼠在人们心中有特定的语境。而且它往往被忽视。我认为，人们想当然地认为因为它们太常见了，所以我们已经掌握了关于松鼠所需的一切知识，但事实恰恰相反。事实上，此前从未有人费心做过中央公园松鼠普查，去收集关于我们景观中最常见动物之一的最基本数据点，这揭示了我们在松鼠问题上存在一种社会盲点。长期以来，我们一直把它们视为理所当然，包括这些
squirrels came from. The squirrels we see in our cities and towns are so every day, so ubiquitous, so just there, that it's easy to assume they've always been there. But the truth is, they haven't. In the mid-19th century, you could walk through a place like Boston or Philadelphia or Manhattan and you would not see a single squirrel. This is Etienne Benson. He's a historian of environmental science at the University of Pennsylvania. And he says the cities of the early 19th century were effectively squirreless. These were animals you could only see if you left the city.
松鼠的来源故事。我们在城市和城镇中看到的松鼠是如此日常，如此普遍，如此“就在那里”，以至于很容易认为它们一直都在那里。但事实并非如此。在19世纪中叶，你走在波士顿、费城或曼哈顿这样的地方，根本看不到一只松鼠。这是艾蒂安·本森。他是宾夕法尼亚大学的环境科学历史学家。他说，19世纪初的城市实际上是没有松鼠的。这些动物只有当你离开城市时才能见到。
And then even perhaps left the farm, right, and went deep into the woods. And it was only when you went deep into the woods that you would have the chance to see something like a squirrel. In fact, squirrels were considered so elusive, the very wealthy like to keep them as exotic pets. In 1856, an article in the New York Times described how one such pet escaped from its owner's home in Manhattan and when it was discovered in a tree, a crowd of people gathered in amazement trying to lure it down. Eventually the crowd grew so large and rowdy that the police had to forcibly disperse it. So how did these eastern grace girls, these reclusive woodlandland creatures make their way into our urban spaces.
甚至可能要离开农场，深入森林。只有当你深入森林时，才有机会看到像松鼠这样的动物。事实上，松鼠曾被认为非常难以捉摸，以至于富人们喜欢把它们当作异国宠物来饲养。1856年，《纽约时报》的一篇文章描述了一只这样的宠物如何从曼哈顿主人的家中逃脱，当它在树上被发现时，一群人惊奇地围拢过来，试图诱捕它。最终，人群变得如此庞大且喧闹，警察不得不强行驱散他们。那么，这些东部灰松鼠，这些隐居的林地生物，是如何进入我们的城市空间的呢？
Well, for starters, as Etienne, they didn't, at least not on their own. What was so fascinating to me was to find out that they had been intentionally introduced. The scrolls that we all take for granted as we walk through the park or on our way to the gym or the office are only there because we put them there. They were deliberately brought into cities and fed and sheltered. The first city that we know of to introduce squirrels was Philadelphia in 1847.
嗯，首先，正如艾蒂安所说，它们并不是自己进来的，至少不是自发进来的。让我感到非常着迷的是，发现它们是被有意引入的。我们走在公园里或去健身房、办公室路上视为理所当然的松鼠，之所以在那里，是因为我们把它们放进去的。它们是被特意带进城市，并得到喂养和庇护的。我们所知第一个引入松鼠的城市是1847年的费城。
Like many East Coast cities of the mid 19th century, it was already a highly urban environment. People yearned for a taste of the wilderness that the squirrel was seen to embody. They were captured in the wilderness, brought into the city, and placed on a single tree, almost as if they were animals in a menagerie or a zoo. The tree was in the middle of a small public square, and it was equipped with a wooden shelter and a fence,
像19世纪中叶的许多东海岸城市一样，它已经是一个高度城市化的环境。人们渴望体验松鼠所体现的那种荒野气息。它们在荒野中被捕获，带进城市，被安置在一棵树上，就像动物园里的动物一样。那棵树位于一个小公共广场的中央，配有一个木制遮蔽所和栅栏，
so the squirrels could stay safe from the elements, and any would-be predators in their little squirrel home. A few other cities like Boston replicated this model, and at first the number of squirrels was teeny tiny. Philadelphia started out with only three. Think of it as a trial run. Only this first trial run? It went terribly.
这样松鼠就可以在它们的小松鼠屋里免受风吹雨打和任何潜在捕食者的伤害。波士顿等其他一些城市也效仿了这种模式，起初松鼠的数量非常少。费城最初只有三只。把它看作是一次试运行。只是这第一次试运行？结果非常糟糕。
When I started working on this topic, I thought, okay, you introduce a few squirrels into an urban park. In a few years, you're, you introduce a few squirrels into an urban park. In a few years, you're going to have thousands of squirrels, no problem. But at the very beginning, they were essentially incapable of surviving. The cities of the 19th century just didn't have the kind of large parks an extensive tree cover we see today. When you thought about urban landscapes, they were very unfriendly to an animal that required trees for food.
当我开始研究这个课题时，我想，好吧，你在城市公园里引入几只松鼠。几年后，你就会有成千上万只松鼠，没问题。但在最初，它们基本上无法生存。19世纪的城市根本没有我们今天看到的那些大公园和广阔的树木覆盖。当你想到城市景观时，它们对需要树木作为食物的动物非常不友好。
In the classic storybook image of a squirrel, it's always clutching an acorn. And that's basically true. A wild squirrel requires deciduous nut bearing plants such as oak trees in order to survive. Without trees, the city had to provide for the squirrels. But the squirrel feed often proved to be either insufficient or nutritionally worthless. So those first squirrels either died off, were killed, or were adopted as pets. In 1855, a reporter for the Boston Evening Transcript described the introduction of squirrels as, quote, an absurd and reprehensible experiment. All of which raises a question. Why are there now squirrels everywhere in American cities?
在松鼠的经典故事书形象中，它总是抓着一颗橡子。这基本属实。野生松鼠需要落叶坚果类植物（如橡树）才能生存。没有树木，城市就必须供养松鼠。但松鼠饲料往往被证明要么不足，要么毫无营养价值。所以那些最初的松鼠要么死掉，要么被杀，要么被当作宠物领养。1855年，波士顿《晚间誊本报》的一位记者将引入松鼠描述为“一种荒谬且应受谴责的实验”。所有这些都引出了一个问题：为什么现在美国城市的到处都是松鼠？
I think it's more a model of if you build it, they will come. Gabriel Willow is a naturalist who specializes in animal species that live in urban environments. So I study nature and educate people about the natural world, specifically in New York City. And he says that in the late 19th century, green spaces like New York's were undergoing a transformation. Areas of an open land, once multipurpose fields
我认为这更像是“如果你建造它，它们就会来”的模式。加布里埃尔·威洛是一位专门研究城市环境中动物物种的博物学家。我研究自然并向人们普及自然世界，特别是在纽约市。他说，在19世纪末，像纽约这样的绿地正在经历一场变革。曾经作为多功能场地的开阔地，
used for everything from cattle grazing, just lotter houses and militia training, were being transformed into spaces of leisure. And by the 1870s, city dwellers were leaving behind small busy squares in favor of large idyllic parks. And although they were designed for people, these new urban oasis just might be the best thing to ever happen to the eastern gray squirrel.
从牛群放牧到屠宰场和民兵训练，都被改造成了休闲空间。到了1870年代，城市居民开始放弃狭小拥挤的广场，转而青睐大型田园式公园。虽然它们是为人类设计的，但这些新的城市绿洲可能恰好是东部灰松鼠遇到的最好的事情。
Because the parks weren't just big, they were also designed to mimic the natural world. Take Central Park and Prospect Park in New York, for example, both designed by Calvert Vox and Frederick Law Homestead. They were working with the existing geology and hydrology. They took naturally existing small ponds or marshy areas and made lakes out of them. They also chose to keep the areas dramatic rocky outcroppings, instead of blasting them away, as have been done with the rest of the city's grid. And so they were working with certain natural elements.
因为这些公园不仅大，而且设计初衷就是模仿自然世界。以纽约的中央公园和展望公园为例，它们都是由卡尔弗特·沃克斯和弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德设计的。他们利用了现有的地质和水文条件。他们将天然的小池塘或沼泽地改造成了湖泊。他们还选择保留了那些引人注目的岩石露头，而不是像城市其他网格区域那样将其炸平。所以他们是在利用某些自然元素。
These natural parks were filled with hedges and lakes and streams and lots and lots of trees, including to the great fortune of squirrels everywhere. Oak trees. Red oak is very common, white oak is very common, pin oak is very common. There's a lot of acorns around. Everything a would-be squirrel resident might want or need. And it was in this oak-dotted acorn-stroon landscape in Central Park in 1877 that a handful of eastern gray squirrels were introduced for a second trial run. And it was in that landscape that these schools virtually exploded in population. By the turn of the century, what had started as just a few dozen squirrels now numbered in the...
这些自然公园里种满了树篱、湖泊、溪流，还有许许多多的树木，包括让各地松鼠感到万分幸运的——橡树。红橡树很常见，白橡树很常见，针橡树也很常见。周围有很多橡子。这正是松鼠居民可能想要或需要的一切。正是在1877年中央公园这片橡树点缀、橡子遍地的景观中，少数东部灰松鼠被引入进行了第二次试运行。正是在那片景观中，这些松鼠的种群数量几乎呈爆炸式增长。到了世纪之交，最初只有几十只的松鼠，数量现在已经达到……
actually, this is around the time that people just stopped counting. I mean, how could you, with so many squirrels running around? Guesses ranged from the high hundreds to over 5,000. In central park and beyond, squirrels became as commonplace as fire hydrants and telephone poles and all the other newfound accessories of the urban landscape. And as this new approach to urban park lands spread to other cities, so did the idea of populating them with squirrels. Eastern gray squirrels were introduced again to places like
事实上，大约就在这个时候，人们停止了清点。我的意思是，怎么可能数得清呢，有那么多松鼠跑来跑去？猜测从几百只到超过5000只不等。在中央公园及其他地方，松鼠变得像消防栓、电线杆以及城市景观中所有其他新发现的附属物一样司空见惯。随着这种城市公园建设的新方法传播到其他城市，用松鼠填充它们的想法也随之传播开来。东部灰松鼠再次被引入到像
Philadelphia and Boston and west coast cities like Seattle Vancouver and San Francisco. Eastern Grey's were also introduced overseas to England, Italy and South Africa. And it wasn't just the oak trees in these newly lush environments that were providing sustenance for the squirrels. At the time, people considered it their moral duty to feed them. Up until the early 20th century, the dominant way of understanding the proper relationship between humans and animals in this city is centered on charity. It's centered on the idea that humans have an obligation, a responsibility,
费城、波士顿以及西雅图、温哥华和旧金山等西海岸城市。东部灰松鼠也被引入到海外的英国、意大利和南非。而且，在这些新近郁郁葱葱的环境中，不仅有橡树为松鼠提供食物。当时，人们认为喂养它们是自己的道德义务。直到20世纪初，在这个城市中理解人类与动物之间适当关系的主导方式是以慈善为中心的。它以人类有义务、有责任
to create a friendly, welcoming environment for certain kinds of animals to flourish. The ideal city was one that provided a home for good animals and banished the bad. So, if you go back even and read like John James Audebond's account of bird species, he might talk about the bloodthirsty hawk or the wily raven. And so, people used to shoot hawks and falcons and
为某些动物的繁衍创造一个友好、温馨的环境为核心。理想的城市是为好动物提供家园，并驱逐坏动物的城市。所以，如果你回去读约翰·詹姆斯·奥杜邦关于鸟类的记述，他可能会谈到嗜血的鹰或狡猾的乌鸦。因此，人们过去常常射杀鹰、猎鹰和
eagles and other birds of prey because they're predators because they would eat other animals people thought oh they're just mean. Whereas other animals like pigeons and of course squirrels were considered peaceful. More than that they interacted with humans. The site of an undemesticated animal not only approaching you but effectively communicating with you by soliciting food, was a sign of its civilized nature. So it was only proper that you should feed them. Historians would later give these wild animals and the residents who brought them into the city a name, the more than human community.
雕以及其他猛禽，因为它们是捕食者，因为它们会吃掉其他动物，人们认为“哦，它们太坏了”。而鸽子，当然还有松鼠，则被认为是和平的。不仅如此，它们还与人类互动。看到一种未驯化的动物不仅接近你，而且通过索要食物有效地与你沟通，这是它文明天性的标志。所以，喂养它们是理所应当的。历史学家后来给这些野生动物以及将它们带入城市的居民起了一个名字：超越人类的社区。
So the idea was to create a kind of, you might even call it kind of fantasy world in which every animal that is in the city is kind of living peacefully with the others at the indulgence of the humans that run the place. Thanks to the more than human community model, urban squirrels lived large for decades. Nuts, trees, and humans feeding them extra food and killing off all their predators. They had it made. And in the case of New Haven, for example, there's even an article that I found that describes them as becoming so obese that they began to fall from the trees.
所以这个想法是创造一种，你甚至可以称之为一种幻想世界，在这个世界里，城市里的每一种动物都在管理这个地方的人类的纵容下，与其他动物和平共处。多亏了“超越人类的社区”模式，城市松鼠几十年来过着优渥的生活。坚果、树木，还有人类喂给它们额外的食物并消灭了它们所有的天敌。它们真是太幸福了。以纽黑文为例，我甚至发现了一篇文章，描述它们变得如此肥胖，以至于开始从树上掉下来。
As the 19th century led into the 20th, and the squirrels were busy spreading out into suburban addicts and college campuses, no one stopped to wonder if there could be such a thing as too many squirrels. But as hard as it is to admit there is now evidence to suggest there might actually be too many. There is an ongoing attack against the power grid and it's being led by squirrels. Matthew Harper is an information security expert with 20 years of experience and he says when it comes to threats to the US power network, forget terrorism, forget Russian hackers. In the case of the utility infrastructure, it's the humble squirrel that's causing most of the issues.
随着19世纪进入20世纪，松鼠忙着扩散到郊区的阁楼和大学校园，没有人停下来思考是否会有“松鼠过多”这种事。但尽管很难承认，现在有证据表明松鼠可能真的太多了。目前正发生着一场针对电网的攻击，而带头的就是松鼠。马修·哈珀是一位拥有20年经验的信息安全专家，他说，谈到对美国电力网络的威胁，别提恐怖主义，别提俄罗斯黑客。在公用事业基础设施方面，正是这种不起眼的松鼠造成了大部分问题。
By some estimates, one out of every five power outages in the United States are squirrel-related. To be fair to the squirrels, they really start out with the best of intentions. Squirrels need to build mess, and they usually build those nests and trees, but they also build them in anything that looks like a tree, like utility poles or transformers, and like all rodents, a squirrels and size
据估计，美国五分之一的停电事故与松鼠有关。公平地说，松鼠最初确实是出于好意。松鼠需要筑巢，它们通常在树上筑巢，但它们也会在任何看起来像树的东西上筑巢，比如电线杆或变压器，而且像所有啮齿动物一样，松鼠的门牙
or teeth never stop growing, so they have to chew to keep them filed down. They mostly chew bark and branches and nuts, but they also chew things like power cables. So inevitably, some unlucky squirrel will nod through the insulation of a power line, or step on two exposed wires at the same time and… Oh. Killing the squirrel and shorting the system. To keep track of all those system shorts, Matthew runs
永远不会停止生长，所以它们必须通过啃咬来磨短牙齿。它们主要啃咬树皮、树枝和坚果，但也会啃咬电缆之类的东西。因此，不可避免地，一些倒霉的松鼠会咬穿电线的绝缘层，或者同时踩在两根裸露的电线上，然后……哦。松鼠被电死，系统短路。为了追踪所有这些系统短路，马修运营着
a website called CyberSquirrel1. Which is a website which tracks squirrel activities and attacks against the power grid. And yes, this is real. CyberSquirrel1 consists of a big map marking the largest power outages caused by squirrels in the past 30 years. Pick a year and you can find hundreds of pins indicating squirrel incidents, splaid out across the lower 48 in Canada.
一个名为“CyberSquirrel1”的网站。这是一个追踪松鼠活动和针对电网攻击的网站。是的，这是真的。CyberSquirrel1包含一张大地图，标记了过去30年里由松鼠引起的最大规模停电事故。选定一年，你就能找到数百个图钉，显示着松鼠引发的事故，遍布美国本土48州和加拿大。
There's a drop-down menu if you want to see outages caused by other animals, but don't bother. When it comes to power problems, it's mostly just squirrels. Can you give me some examples of squirrel related power outages? I'm just pulling it up now. Squirrel, here we go. Last year 2018 at college in California actually I'm having to cancel classes. Then in November of 2018 a single roving squirrel knocked out three substations in upstate New York causing a string of power outages for more than 12,000 people. That same month, another squirrel took out a polling station in Virginia on the
如果你想查看由其他动物引起的停电，有一个下拉菜单，但别费心了。谈到电力问题，基本上都是松鼠。你能给我举一些松鼠引发停电的例子吗？我正在调取数据。松鼠，找到了。去年2018年，加州的一所大学实际上不得不取消课程。然后在2018年11月，一只流浪松鼠摧毁了纽约州北部的三个变电站，导致超过12000人断电。同一个月，另一只松鼠在
day of the presidential election. Then in December, a squirrel cut the power of an entire shopping mall in South Carolina, one week before Christmas. A particular case in Canada back in April of 2009 impacted 55,000 people. And those are just the big ones. In Austin, Texas, squirrels were responsible for over 400 separate outages in 2015 alone. But the greatest rodent-related outage of all occurred in December of 1987, in the last place you'd ever expect to find an electrocuted squirrel. That story, and more, after this.
总统选举日当天摧毁了弗吉尼亚州的一个投票站。然后在12月，一只松鼠在圣诞节前一周切断了南卡罗来纳州整个购物中心的电力。2009年4月在加拿大发生的一个特殊案例影响了55000人。而这些还只是大事件。仅在2015年，奥斯汀的松鼠就造成了超过400起单独的停电事故。但最严重的啮齿动物相关停电发生在1987年12月，在那个你最意想不到会发现被电死松鼠的地方。那个故事，以及更多内容，稍后继续。
It happened on December 9, 1987. It's kind of sad for me because I am a true animal lover. Joseph San Germino is a retired member of the New York Stock Exchange. That means he used to be one of those guys. You'd see yelling and screaming on the trading room floor. And it's simply this. Back in the day, you know, back in 1987, the New York Stock Exchange was everything to the world. Back then in the 80s, the exchange controlled 85% of the global stock market.
事情发生在1987年12月9日。这对我来说有点难过，因为我是一个真正的动物爱好者。约瑟夫·圣吉米诺是纽约证券交易所的退休成员。这意味着他曾经是那种人。你会看到他们在交易大厅里大喊大叫。事情很简单。在那个年代，你知道，在1987年，纽约证券交易所对世界来说就是一切。那时在80年代，该交易所控制着全球85%的股票市场。
And so traders like Joe, they were the kings of Wall Street. We were the place to go. We were so proud to wear our white badges with our numbers on it and say we worked on the Florida-New York Stock Exchange. But there was also another exchange in town that was slowly chipping away at their market share, their biggest rival, Nasdaq. The Nasdaq was an automated exchange that ran on computers. It didn't need floor traders and the traders that the New York Stock Exchange who made trades
所以像乔这样的交易员，他们是华尔街的国王。我们是人们向往的地方。我们非常自豪地佩戴着带有编号的白色徽章，说我们在纽约证券交易所工作。但城里还有另一个交易所正在慢慢蚕食他们的市场份额，他们最大的竞争对手——纳斯达克。纳斯达克是一个运行在计算机上的自动化交易所。它不需要大厅交易员，而纽约证券交易所那些
in person by hand hated it. So Joe still remembers the glorious day a rumor began to spread among the 4,000 traders on the floor of the exchange. We started hearing that Nasdaq was kind of technical glitch and by the time it got from one end to the exchange to the other it might have talked about 30 seconds. And it just word of mouth, it just flies. Finally, the electronic ticker tape, scrolling along one of the walls of the exchange lit up with the news.
亲手进行交易的交易员们讨厌它。所以乔至今仍记得那个谣言在交易所大厅的4000名交易员中传开的光荣日子。我们开始听说纳斯达克出现了技术故障，从交易所的一端传到另一端可能只用了30秒。这简直是口口相传，飞速传播。最后，沿着交易所墙壁滚动播放的电子行情显示屏亮起了这个消息。
And the ticker tape, the ticker tape was just flying across and we knew. Their deepest, darkest wish had come true. Nasdaq had failed. It was really a magnet. It was a dream and the trading floor erupted. I mean, you could, it was deafening. For 82 minutes on December 9, 1987, Nasdaq was offline, losing an estimated 20 million trades.
行情显示屏上的信息飞速闪过，我们知道了。他们内心深处最黑暗的愿望实现了。纳斯达克崩溃了。这真是一个磁铁。这是一个梦想，交易大厅沸腾了。我的意思是，你可以，那声音震耳欲聋。1987年12月9日，纳斯达克离线了82分钟，估计损失了2000万笔交易。
And then we find out that it wasn't a squirrel. A squirrel had chewed through a power line in Connecticut, where Nasdaq drew its electricity, but it did not affect the New York Stock Exchange, much to the everlasting joy of traders like Joseph San Gio Mino. To Nasdaq, that squirrel was Godzilla. To us, on the New York Stock Exchange, Jimino. America's squirrels have also been wreaking havoc overseas.
然后我们发现，那不是松鼠干的。一只松鼠咬断了康涅狄格州的一条电线，纳斯达克从那里获取电力，但这并没有影响纽约证券交易所，这让像约瑟夫·圣吉米诺这样的交易员感到无比快乐。对纳斯达克来说，那只松鼠就是哥斯拉。对我们纽约证券交易所来说，吉米诺。美国的松鼠也在海外造成了严重破坏。
In Great Britain, Eastern Gray squirrels introduced in 1876, quickly began to displace the native Red Squirrel, driving it to near extinction. And the Eastern Gray Squirrel might be cute, but the Red Squirrel is super cute. To Google it is to love it. And now there's only a few small pockets of red squirrels left in Northern England and Scotland. This despite a massive eradication campaign, to keep the American invaders out of the Scottish Highlands.
在英国，1876年引入的东部灰松鼠迅速开始取代本土的红松鼠，将其逼近灭绝边缘。东部灰松鼠可能很可爱，但红松鼠超级可爱。去谷歌搜一下就会爱上它。现在，英格兰北部和苏格兰只剩下少数几个红松鼠的小聚居区。尽管进行了大规模的根除运动，试图将这些美国入侵者挡在苏格兰高地之外。
In Europe, they're officially an invasive species. But even as American squirrels were taking out shopping malls and stock exchanges and invading foreign countries, the very things that allowed them to proliferate in the first place were slowly being taken away. Starting in the mid-20th century, ecologists, wildlife managers and park officials started to re-examine America's approach to wildlife. They began to argue that predators like coyotes and hawks should no longer be hunted for the sake of a more than human community. That starts to get replaced with a really different view, right? This ecological view in which we understand those relationships
在欧洲，它们被正式列为入侵物种。但即使美国松鼠正在摧毁购物中心和证券交易所并入侵外国，当初让它们得以繁衍的那些条件也正在慢慢消失。从20世纪中叶开始，生态学家、野生动物管理者和公园官员开始重新审视美国对待野生动物的方式。他们开始争论，不应再为了“超越人类的社区”而猎杀像郊狼和鹰这样的捕食者。这种观点开始被一种非常不同的视角所取代，对吧？这种生态视角，我们理解那些
of predation as essential to the ecosystem as a whole. In this new ecological model, the ideal environment was no longer one that corresponded to notions of civilized versus uncivilized species, but one in which a variety of species, predator and prey alike, maintained a natural population balance with only minimal human intervention. It took a few decades for this idea to spread from the national parks into the cities, but by the 1980s it had arrived, along with the predators. Which for an ecologically-minded naturalist like Gabriel Willow is a wonderful thing. Like, Hyodes are coming back on their own.
捕食关系对于整个生态系统至关重要。在这种新的生态模式中，理想的环境不再是对应文明与非文明物种概念的环境，而是一个各种物种，无论是捕食者还是猎物，都能在极少的人为干预下保持自然种群平衡的环境。这种想法从国家公园传播到城市花了数十年时间，但到了1980年代，它已经到来，随之而来的还有捕食者。对于像加布里埃尔·威洛这样具有生态意识的博物学家来说，这是一件美妙的事情。比如，郊狼正在自发地回归。
We're not bringing them back. Ravens, Ravens are nesting in New York City within the last 15 years. We did not reintroduce them. The red-tailed hawk came back of its own accord. Other species we intentionally reintroduced like Paragon Falcons, and their thriving New York City has the highest population density of Paragon Falcons in the world. For most of us, the death of a few squirrels seems like a small price to pay in exchange for this new found biodiversity. Today, there's no shortage of webcams,
我们没有把它们带回来。乌鸦，乌鸦在过去15年里开始在纽约市筑巢。我们没有重新引入它们。红尾鵟是自发回来的。其他我们有意重新引入的物种，比如游隼，它们在纽约市繁衍生息，拥有世界上最高的游隼种群密度。对我们大多数人来说，几只松鼠的死亡似乎是换取这种新发现的生物多样性所付出的微小代价。今天，网络摄像头随处可见，
set up by people who have discovered a hawks nest outside their 12th floor apartment window. And while we've been busy welcoming the squirrel's predators back into our cities, we've also begun to finally withdraw our charity. I think everybody should go check out squirrels. They're pretty cool. I'm team squirrel, you know? I just don't think we need to be feeding them.
由那些发现自家12楼公寓窗外有鹰巢的人设置。当我们忙着欢迎松鼠的天敌回到我们的城市时，我们也终于开始撤回我们的慈善。我认为每个人都应该去看看松鼠。它们很酷。我是松鼠队的，你知道吗？我只是觉得我们没必要喂它们。
Gabriel and other naturalists think feeding squirrels has no place in the new ecological model. Providing bread and other unnatural foods can lead to a variety of health problems. An acclimating squirrels to hand feeding can make them overly dependent on humans and possibly prone to unstable population booms, none of which is ultimately good for the squirrels or the larger environment. Which is why 142 years after welcoming squirrels into the fold of our more than human community, New York City is done given handouts. Good morning.
加布里埃尔和其他博物学家认为，在新的生态模式中，喂养松鼠没有立足之地。提供面包和其他非自然食物会导致各种健康问题。而让松鼠习惯于手喂会使它们过度依赖人类，并可能导致不稳定的种群激增，这些最终对松鼠或更大的环境都没有好处。这就是为什么在欢迎松鼠进入我们的“超越人类的社区”142年后，纽约市不再提供施舍了。早上好。
Today is March 1st, 2019, and the time is 12.05. Welcome to Palme Fritz Recreation Center. This past winter, the New York City Parks Department held a hearing for a proposed rule change that would make it illegal to feed any wild animal in the parks. This hearing is tended to solicit comments regarding the proposed rule changes. These comments will become part of the public record. Gabriel Willow was there too. Although it didn't go down quite the way he thought it would.
今天是2019年3月1日，时间是12点05分。欢迎来到帕尔梅·弗里茨娱乐中心。去年冬天，纽约市公园管理局举行了一场听证会，讨论一项拟议的规则变更，该变更将使在公园内喂养任何野生动物成为非法行为。本次听证会旨在征求关于拟议规则变更的意见。这些意见将成为公共记录的一部分。加布里埃尔·威洛也去了。虽然事情的发展并不完全像他想的那样。
I didn't really expect it to be quite as skewed as it was in terms of almost everybody there I was speaking against the regulations. His criminal act that runs against the morals and rules of the civilized society. New York Park says that the squirrels, they should be squirrels, they should be animals and flies like they do in the wild except for one thing. The parks aren't the wild. I don't know that I've encountered that many squirrel and pigeon feeding fans in one place before. And although they agreed the animals should be eating healthy food, they were not buying
我真的没想到它会如此一边倒，几乎所有在场的人都在反对这些规定。这是违背文明社会道德和规则的犯罪行为。纽约公园说松鼠应该是松鼠，它们应该是动物，应该像在野外一样生活，只有一点除外。公园不是野外。我不知道我以前是否在同一个地方遇到过这么多松鼠和鸽子喂养爱好者。虽然他们同意动物应该吃健康的食物，但他们并不买账
into the ecological model. Here, the parks are not nature. They're an artificial situation. We are part of your environment. You can't change that. When people express concern that certain animals in certain parks might starve, Gabriel tried to stand up for the hands-off approach. The problem of them starving due to lack of food is because there's a higher population,
生态模式。在这里，公园不是自然。它们是一种人工环境。我们是你环境的一部分。你无法改变这一点。当人们表达对某些公园里的某些动物可能会饿死的担忧时，加布里埃尔试图支持这种“不干预”的方法。它们因缺乏食物而饿死的问题是因为种群数量过高，
because they're being fed. It's a cycle. But the applause was tepid. Thank you. It was not as poorly received as the founder and director of the Wild Bird Fund. She was also against feeding. She was actually booed. Exactly what effect the blanket ban would have on wildlife populations is unclear. But regardless of the ecological impact, the biggest takeaway from the hearing was that
因为它们被喂养了。这是一个循环。但掌声很冷淡。谢谢。这并没有像野生鸟类基金会的创始人和主任那样受到冷遇。她也反对喂养。她实际上被嘘了。全面禁令对野生动物种群到底会有什么影响尚不清楚。但无论生态影响如何，听证会最大的收获是
the concept of the more than human community that was still going strong. I'm here today as a voice for New York City's non-human residents because I see what's happening to our wildlife neighbors as really truly tragic. The feeling that these animals are fellow citizens and should be treated with the same consideration has never fully gone away. It is not just about what we want, it's about what the squirrels and all of the other than human beings in our parks want to and they are constituents of New York City. People love to feed the animals in the park.
“超越人类的社区”这一概念依然强劲。我今天作为纽约市非人类居民的代言人来到这里，因为我看到我们的野生动物邻居正在经历的事情确实非常悲惨。这些动物是我们的同胞，应该受到同样的对待，这种感觉从未完全消失。这不仅仅是关于我们想要什么，而是关于松鼠和我们公园里所有其他非人类生物想要什么，它们是纽约市的选民。人们喜欢喂公园里的动物。
On any park bench in any city, you'll see people throwing crumbs to the birds and the birds approaching for more. It's one way we feel a connection to nature. For just a moment, both human and animal are doing something together. That shared experience between species, that's what the people at the hearing didn't want taken away. Gabriel Willow also believes that there is value in connecting with these animals, but he sees it as a reason not to be them. I think people really crave a direct interaction and connection with nature, and so what I was saying when I spoke was like look.
在任何城市的任何公园长椅上，你都会看到人们向鸟儿投掷面包屑，而鸟儿走过来索要更多。这是我们感受与自然联系的一种方式。在那一刻，人类和动物都在共同做某事。物种之间那种共享的体验，就是听证会上的人们不想被剥夺的东西。加布里埃尔·威洛也认为与这些动物建立联系是有价值的，但他认为这正是不要喂养它们的理由。我认为人们真的渴望与自然进行直接的互动和联系，所以我发言时说的是，看。
Please go to the park observe wildlife feel that connection you don't need to touch them you don't need to pet them you don't need to hold them you don't need to feed them like it's actually more. Interesting and more valuable to stand back and see an animal exhibiting a more natural behavior. Watch a squirrel long enough and you'll see it play tricks on other squirrels. If a squirrel carrying an acorn believes it's being watched, it will dig a hole, pantomime putting the acorn in the hole, and then cover the hole back up, all while hiding the real acorn in its mouth, just to throw its fellow squirrels off the scent.
请去公园观察野生动物，感受那种联系，你不需要触摸它们，不需要抚摸它们，不需要抱着它们，不需要喂养它们。实际上，退后一步，看着动物展现出更自然的习性，会更有趣，也更有价值。观察一只松鼠足够久，你就会看到它捉弄其他松鼠。如果一只带着橡子的松鼠认为自己被监视了，它会挖一个洞，假装把橡子放进洞里，然后把洞盖上，同时把真正的橡子藏在嘴里，只是为了让它的同伴松鼠偏离目标。
Squirrels have been seen carefully organizing their acorns by size and shape before they bury them. Biologists believe it's a mnemonic device that helps the squirrels remember what they buried where. They have a specific call when they see a predator, so if you learn a little bit of squirrel language, like I know the hot call, so if I hear that, I'll look up and often see a hawk. So for them to just sort of allow us to be there,
人们观察到松鼠在埋藏橡子之前会仔细地按大小和形状进行整理。生物学家认为这是一种记忆辅助手段，帮助松鼠记住它们把什么埋在了哪里。它们在看到捕食者时有特定的叫声，所以如果你学习一点松鼠语言，比如我知道鹰的叫声，如果我听到那个，我会抬头看，通常会看到一只鹰。所以对它们来说，只是让我们待在那里，
but go about their day-to-day life is so much more powerful for me. There's more than one way to connect to the animals with whom we share our cities, whether it's listening to the yipping of coyotes in the middle of the night, setting up a webcam for the hawk nest outside your window, or counting all the squirrels in Central Park. In March, Jamie Allen and the other team members of the squirrel census finished gathering their data.
但继续它们的日常生活对我来说更有力量。与我们共享城市的动物建立联系的方式不止一种，无论是听深夜郊狼的叫声，为窗外的鹰巢设置网络摄像头，还是清点中央公园里的所有松鼠。三月，杰米·艾伦和松鼠普查的其他团队成员完成了数据收集。
They plan to reveal the squirrel abundance number in June. Atian Benson's, as he doesn't know how many schools there are in Central Park, but he thinks he does understand why everyone is so eager to find out. You know, one of the appeals of a school census is just the same appeal that has existed since the 1850s, which is it's clear to people that the world around them is not only inhabited by humans, but it is this multi-species place. And I think there is a need and a desire there to know something about your neighbors.
他们计划在六月公布松鼠丰度数值。艾蒂安·本森说，他不知道中央公园里有多少只松鼠，但他认为他明白为什么每个人都如此渴望知道。你知道，松鼠普查的吸引力之一，和自1850年代以来存在的吸引力是一样的，那就是人们清楚地意识到，他们周围的世界不仅有人类居住，而且是一个多物种共存的地方。我认为人们有一种需求和渴望，想要了解一些关于邻居的信息。
The census is a form of appreciation, a way of recognizing that the squirrels are there. And that in, is beautiful. 99% of Vizbo West produced this week by Caitlin Swaljay and edited by Joe Rosenberg. It makes him tech production by Sheree Fusif, music by Sean Rial. Additional music in this episode was composed by Jenny Conley-Drizos, John Newfeld, and
普查是一种欣赏的形式，一种承认松鼠存在的方式。这本身就很美。《99%隐形》本周由凯特琳·斯瓦尔杰制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑。技术制作由谢丽·福西夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。本集中的额外音乐由珍妮·康利-德里佐斯、约翰·纽菲尔德和
A Query. Kitty Mingle is a senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor, Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffman, Emmett Fitzgerald Terran Mazza, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Susan Kirby and Andrew Christopher, whose interviews we did not get to include in the episode But without whose help we could not have made this story As for the squirrel census
A Query创作。基蒂·明格尔是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特劳夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎、薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢苏珊·柯比和安德鲁·克里斯托弗，我们没能将他们的采访放入本集，但没有他们的帮助，我们无法完成这个故事。至于松鼠普查，
Following the announcement of the squirrel abundance number there will be a squirrel masquerade ball and dance party Held at the Explorer's Club in New York City for details. Check out the squirrel census dot com in the coming weeks New York City. For details check out the squirrelsensors.com in the coming weeks. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org.
在公布松鼠丰度数值后，将举办一场松鼠化装舞会和派对，地点在纽约市的探险家俱乐部。详情请在未来几周查看 squirrelcensus.com。详情请在未来几周查看 squirrelcensus.com。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心 Radio Row 制作。《99%隐形》是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上 @RomanMars 或 @99PIorg 关注我。
Run Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you can join the rest of us in the more than human community at 99yanipi.org Radio to be on you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也有。但你可以在 99yanipi.org 加入我们，成为“超越人类的社区”的一员。RadioTopia。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。